welcome to
this studio um you're from scotland yard
i am yes and this case is still very
emotional in in norway and i understand
there
have been developments
which we will come back to but but
let's start with the beginning five
years ago a norwegian student
was reported missing in london
when were you brought in from homicide
so five years ago i was a senior
investigating officer of one of our
homicide teams
so i had a team of 35 people and in
london we do what we call an on-call
system and so that your standby should a
crime of that kind of seriousness occur
myself and my team would be called out
to deal with it um and i was on call on
that weekend
um so we got called by the local borough
and i think uh
martina been reported missing on the
friday evening
it was a relatively low grade assessment
at that time a young woman in london
socializing with people she knew
by saturday evening it started to get
higher up our scale and that's just
because of the time
yeah the time that it's gone you know
the fact that there had been no contact
from her whatsoever it became more and
more out of character um there were more
things that just added concern to police
and then in the early hours of the
saturday morning when you know another
night out that had come and gone and
martina hadn't come to the usual places
it got passed on to local detectives
and they did some various inquiries
through the evening and into sunday
morning and then they called me
so i attended uh the location of the
suspect in this case who was the person
she'd last been seen with
went into the flat
and from what i saw there um i i kind of
knew that this was not going to have a
happy ending
so i was in the process of calling my
team
you know you've read the scene you think
what to do next you decide your actions
and you work from the inside out it was
all about that building to start with
and so instigated some activity in the
building
and within the hour martinez body was
discovered
the man you wanted to talk to
you then found out he was gone
yes the same day
he'd gone we believe before martinez was
even reported missing by her friends
and he was gone to yemen
yeah i mean we didn't know that right at
the start we knew that he'd left the
country
um
and inquiries went to you know from that
point on it became about locating this
really important person to speak to in
the inquiry but then how do you work
from day to day for five years how what
do you do you know it's about taking
things in bite sizes isn't it my first
priority was to gather the evidence you
know my role is to prove or disprove
what may have occurred you know which
ended in martina's death that's my role
i gather that evidence i secure that
evidence that evidence told me there was
an individual that i wanted to speak to
so only when i gathered that's evidence
could i then get a warrant
to show that he was now wanted and then
it's about locating that person and
trying to get him back to the uk it must
be extremely frustrating of course it is
you know it's
it's frustrating for me as an
investigator um
the family who just do not get any form
of closure they
you know have to go this prolonged pain
because it just can't be resolved and
and it's um it's difficult to stomach
you know that it's just because it's a
certain person of a certain nationality
it was in a specific location of the
world it's not the same for everyone
else
and it's it's deeply unfair the fact
that the suspect's father is a very
wealthy man does that
i mean what role does that play for the
investigation um you know it'd be naive
to say it has no bearing on it of course
it does you know there is a
family there who are very powerful who
are very wealthy from that region and
and of course it it changes the game but
do you go to yemen yourself or do you
send people to yemen or how do you work
uh you know i've often been uh asked
that and i haven't been to yemen and i
think it surprises a lot of people but
you know i have no jurisdiction in yemen
it would really serve no purpose for me
to go there i i i can't take any action
while i'm there
so no haven't traveled to yemen do you
you know the case here in britain yeah
yeah
especially when it first
broke it was a huge story
very shocking how
how involved um
as a as a
as a person as a
as a
private person how involved can you be
in in her family in this story
however um you always seek to be
professional but um you know frankly you
can't do a good job unless there's a bit
of
humanity to you and you recognize that
and um you know in the role
that i do investigating murder um
it's it must be unique you know you come
across people
who you would never ordinarily meet in
your life you probably would never meet
them at all in your life and you come
into their lives at a time when they're
facing you know a horrific reality
um and you know they're trying to come
to terms with what's happened they can't
quite understand it they have many
questions for which there are no answers
and they look at you and you know you
become their rock really and you you are
their hope and
and they trust you and and it's um it's
a responsibility that i've always had
respectful so you've been a part of
the memorial service and you've been a
part of the family and family sorrow in
a way yeah it's really important to me
that um you know it shows the family
your commitment it shows that you are
passionate about this that you will work
very hard for them and it's important
for you know us the police to understand
what's on the other side of our
professional job of investigating it's
really important are you saying it's
important to invest emotions in
investigation definitely definitely of
course it does you know you need
something that gets you out of bed in
the morning to get to work and
and make those decisions and and move on
and get knocked down and pick yourself
up and think of something else to do you
know and it's you get that from the
family you know they they need you
do you think this can be a good
motivator for an investigator you know
we've heard it obviously it is a good
motivator
it's more passion than
more passion than i expected but i
understand it
there has been some some developments
recently can you tell us about that
well i mean the developments are always
ongoing you know and we are ever
grateful that it gets addressed at a
high level what's been significant to us
at the moment is that we've actually you
know had an initial meeting with some
legal representation for the suspect
in this country
and so there are people now that we can
have a dialogue with is a platform to
try and to move this forward because
i guess some of the problem with this
case it's been very hard for me for
anyone to understand what possible
reason other than evading you know the
facing of justice there is not to come
to this country
um you know we've got a well developed
we've got a mature criminal justice
system you know it's well regarded and
so we need to understand if there are
reasons there which we can overcome that
we can address we need to do that and be
able to move on
so you are in dialogue now yes
are you are you confident there will be
closure
you know
never say never i personally yes i think
that day will come
people slip up it's really hard to be
good that long and to not put your foot
out of place and
you know we'll be there we'll be ready
to take him when he does do that
thank you very much
and thank you all for for for joining us
tonight
please welcome ed stafford
you